from a World War II film about a dressed
up corpse to a creepy horror comedy
about a satanic child Netflix has a
whole slew of hidden gems that are just
waiting to be discovered by you
30 minutes or less is a lively action
comedy anchored by some of the strongest
comic voices of the New Millennium in
the film Jesse Eisenberg plays Nick
Davis a nerdy pizza delivery boy
Tick Tock however one of Nick's
deliveries goes haywire when two wannabe
criminals take him hostage attach a bomb
to his chest and force him to rob a bank
well aware of his limitations and the
Dark absurdity of the situation Nick
brings along chat an old friend whose
relationship with him has grown strained
if Nick and Chet want to survive their
predicament they'll have to solve their
issues and figure out how to be Pals
again Peter Bradshaw of the Guardian had
this to say about 30 minutes or less
it's entirely ridiculous but it gallops
cheerfully along everything is carried
off with flair and ingenuity
the best science fiction Tales aren't
just about unsure Futures and alien
worlds they also use new and unfamiliar
environments to point out universal
truths about The Human Condition the
script for advantageous is that kind of
story the film is set in a
technologically advanced New York City
of tomorrow where the Divide between the
rich and the poor is more pronounced
than ever as a result of this class
struggle mothers will do absolutely
anything to make sure their children get
an upper hand in life for Gwen a wealthy
cosmetic procedure salesperson who gets
fired right as her daughter enters an
expensive school that means agreeing to
be a test subject for a painful
procedure the procedure involves having
her Consciousness transferred entirely
into a new body complications arise
calling into question whether or not
this new Gwen is even Gwen at all in its
review of advantageous the magazine of
fantasy and science fiction called the
film quiet and affecting
a young woman named Alice secretly
performs explicit acts as Lola Lola cam
girl extraordinaire though she's willing
to do whatever it takes to rise through
the ranks of popularity on her CD
hosting site Alice is able to keep an
emotional distance from her work that is
until a dark contingent encourages her
to perform a shocking act of violence in
his review of the film Tiber of the
Boston Globe wrote cam plays with both
psychological horror genre tropes and
darker existential themes and its
clear-eyed view of the drab realities of
a cam girl's life is both refreshing and
Ultra creepy
you might be wondering what Dolomite is
my name is doing on a list of underrated
movies after all the film was a favorite
among critics and was nominated for a
few Awards but it was also snubbed by
the Academy Awards not receiving a
single Oscar nomination so the film is
on this list precisely because of the
snubs it received it's a shame the movie
didn't get more recognition because
Dolomite is my name is terrific Dolomite
is my name tells the story of Rudy Ray
Moore comedian and black exploitation
actor known for his Dolomite movies the
movie covers Moore's life from the
period right before he became a star all
the way to the Los Angeles premiere of
his first film Eddie Murphy and a
comeback of sorts does an outstanding
job as more
name and rapping and tapping is my game
not only is Murphy great as more but his
co-stars are amazing too Wesley Snipes
is wonderful playing the director of
dolomite while Devine Joy Randolph is
tremendous as Lady Reed Moore's longtime
friend and confidante the costumes by
oscar-winning designer Ruthie Carter are
also a standout in this well-made comedy
a coming-of-age story about people just
trying to find their place in the world
dumplin boasts a cast led by comedy
Legend Jennifer Aniston and charismatic
star on the rise Danielle McDonald the
latter plays Willow Dean Dixon she
prefers to be called will but her mother
insists on referring to her as dumplin a
supremely confident and witty teenager
dumplin stands up for herself against
bullies who criticize her for her weight
standing up to her mother however is a
lot harder so what better way to
establish herself than competing in her
mother's beloved mistine Blue Bonnet
pageant what initially begins as a
protest against pageants and her mother
soon becomes a celebration of all types
of beauty thus prompting other
overlooked Misfits to join dumplin in
her review of the film Elizabeth
Weitzman of the rap wrote this is a
generous movie and an unrepentant
fantasy at that so it's hard not to meet
it with open-heartedness
the Netflix series The Last kingdom is a
historical drama about King Alfred the
Great of what would become England the
show Blends actual events from the 9th
century with fiction to tell the story
of how kingdoms were brought together to
form a United England at the start the
land has been captured by the invading
Vikings with only King Alfred and his
Kingdom of Wessex standing in the way to
Total Domination
[Music]
the last Kingdom tells the story of
utread of bebenber a noble Saxon who
gets kidnapped as a slave and then
raised by the Danes utread is conflicted
to whom does he pledge his Allegiance so
he's ultimately forced to choose between
the people that raised him and the land
of his birth the series has everything
you'd want in a historical drama
covering this time period brutal
fighting great characters and intriguing
story loads of death and gorgeous
cinematography so if you're in the
market for a show full of English
accents and good old-fashioned swordplay
the last kingdom is for you
an unassuming movie but once speckled
with action tension and agonizing
personal drama leave no Trace is about
the unbreakable bond between a parent
and child will is an Iraq war veteran
suffering from post-traumatic stress
disorder Will's PTSD is so severe that
he's become deeply uncomfortable
interacting with people so he raises his
teenage daughter Tom in vast forested
Parks outside of Portland after
authorities find them and set them up
with a home on a Christmas tree farm Tom
enjoys the stability she also likes
being around other kids but when will
makes them leave again Thomas forced to
choose between her family and her own
path in his review of the film David
Stratton of the Australian wrote Leaf no
Trace is a small film but a quietly
memorable one
little evil is a horror comedy about an
eager to please guy who marries a woman
who has a son from a previous marriage
he's desperate to connect with the
inscrutable little guy so that the three
of them can all come together as a happy
blended family that's a difficult task
as the kid is actually the spawn of
Satan needless to say he's not afraid to
unleash Pure Evil and Terror on his
well-meaning new stepdad Amanda Sink of
the Hollywood Outsider wrote little evil
is The Omen by way of Sean of the Dead
Maniac is hard to categorize it's a
Darkly comic often surreal and lightly
dystopian miniseries said in a future
world where gadgetry and pharmaceuticals
have rapidly progressed in the series
Annie who's desperate and guilt-ridden
and Owen who's the troubled black sheep
of a rich family locked down for a
heavily controlled psychological drug
trial the trial is operated by The
Eccentric Dr James K mantle Ray who is
literally and explicitly in love with
Machinery he also lives in the shadow of
his mother Dr Greta mantelray a popular
pop psychologist and best-selling author
the series also explores the minds of
Owen and Annie who live out their
deepest fears and insecurities in
disparate ways such as an exotic animal
Heist and a lord of the rings-esque
fantasy not only dazzling and
challenging Maniac manages to be vibrant
ridiculous and to varying degrees moving
according to Willa paskin of slate
operation mincemeat tells a fascinating
and gripping but little-known World War
II Story one so filled with audacious
and and foolhardy participants that it's
hard to believe it's real said in 1943
the Allied Forces planned to stop
Hitler's conquest of Europe with a
multi-pronged attack on Sicily a
troubling option because it would ensure
Mass casualties on both sides and so two
Elite British Intelligence Officers come
up with a bizarre scheme known as
operation mincemeat our other deception
plans or strategies designed to confuse
the enemy throm-off balance mincemeat on
the other hand is an outright lie with
plenty of help from higher-ups and the
rank and file they dress up in abandoned
corpse in a Royal Marines uniform and
plant evidence of a false Allied
invasion on it from there the
Intelligence Officers wait for the axis
forces to discover the dressed up corpse
and act accordingly on the
misinformation in his Rave of the film
Jake Wilson of the age wrote operation
mincemeat is a genuine surprise package
it prompts Nostalgia if not for the war
then for an almost equally distant era
of skillfully crafted entertainment
after expelling Belgian colonialists in
1960 the Congo declared independence so
in 1961 the United Nations arrived to
help support the newly formed government
U.N peacekeeping troops soon got caught
up in a civil war between the Democratic
Republic of the Congo and the natural
resource heavy secessionist state of
katanga the siege of jadeville tells of
a little-known moment in this seven-day
conflict in which three thousand
mercenaries working for mining companies
in katanga attacked the 150 Irish troops
serving under the U.N led by commandant
Pat Quinlan the defense held its ground
pushing back the thousands of attackers
while waiting for reinforcements to
arrive the film is a harrowing
high-stakes drama loaded with military
action and almost unbelievable acts of
courage and tactical Brilliance if
you're a fan of War movies The Siege of
jottville is not to be missed
the fear of turning into one's parents
as they settle into adulthood is an
extremely common worry it's also the
basis for the psychological supernatural
horror film AMA Amanda and her teenage
daughter Chrissy enjoy an idyllic
existence on their Farm hanging out and
tending to bees however everything
changes when the remains of Amanda's
mother arrive from Korea AMA wasn't a
good mom she was cruel and abusive and
it was the reason for a long
estrangement but what remains of her
bodily form literally haunts Amanda as
she quickly evolves into her mother at
her most monstrous and horrific while
critics found the film to be uneven AMA
is still worth a watch the film is
original and quirky while its
unpredictable plot and character choices
subvert many horror movie cliches
foreign